ha sido una jornada electoral larguísima
que comenzó a las 7 de la mañana con el
voto del líder supremo de la revolución
y terminó a la medianoche para dar
tiempo que aquellas personas que se
decidieron a votar a última hora
pudieran hacerlo había sido una jornada
muy caliente sobre los 40 grados
centígrados en teherán lo que hizo que
la gente solamente decidiera salir a la
última hora por eso es muy difícil
prever en este momento cuál fue la
participación que las encuestas ponían
sobre el 44% lo que sería la más baja de
toda la historia de la república
islámica otro motivo que dicen los
observadores que pudo haber motivado a
una mayor participación no fue el
presidente sino esos consejos comunales
a los cuales especialmente las
poblaciones más pequeñas la gente quiso
votar esto también fue una campaña
electoral marcada por la figura de casen
suleimán el general de las fuerzas
coaches que fue asesinado el 2020 por
orden de donald trump muchas de las
personas que vimos esta mañana decían
que votaban en su memoria
de él y de todos los mártires que habían
dejado su sangre por irán a estas
alturas se sigue dando como favorito al
jefe de la justicia al clérigo ibrahim
khraishi pero solamente sabremos mañana
quién es el ganador